hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how does the ABIM
choosing wisely initiative affect
diagnostic laboratory medicine presented
by George frits ma proprietor at the
frits ma factor your inner active
hemostasis resource I'm Suzy Valdez of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by elaborates language is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice that
you'll be viewing this presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon at the lower
right if you have an H levels seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right will use
that Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem good news this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process to
obtain those credits please join me now
in welcoming our presenter George fritz
ma I will now turn the presentation over
to him welcome George
hello everybody this is George and the
title of my talk is medical laboratory
science educators choose wisely it's a
discussion of the choosing wisely
program that is developed by the
American Board of Internal Medicine
Foundation and Consumer Reports I'd like
to read to you the commentary that you
can find on the choosing wisely website
in which it gives a little history of
choosing wisely in 2010 howard brodie
m.d. published medicines ethical
responsibility for healthcare reform the
top five list in new england journal of
medicine and this piece dr. Brody called
on u.s. medical specialty societies to
identify five overused tests and
treatments that did not provide
meaningful benefit for patients shortly
after the National physicians Alliance
piloted the five things concept through
an ABI M Foundation grant and created a
set of specific steps physicians in
internal medicine family medicine and
pediatrics could take in their practices
to promote the more effective use of
healthcare resources these lists were
first published in archives of internal
medicine and building on the work of dr.
Brody and the NPA in April 2012 the ABIM
foundation along with Consumer Reports
formally launched the choosing wisely
campaign the release of top five lists
from nine specialty societies the
widespread media coverage from nearly
every top-tier outlet along with
positive reaction among the healthcare
community inspired 17 additional
societies
join and to release lists in February
2013 more than 70 societies comprising
over 1 million clinicians are now
partners of the choosing wisely campaign
in 2013 the ABIM foundation received a
grant from the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation to advance the choosing
wisely campaign by funding 21 state
medical societies specialty societies
and Regional Health collaboratives to
help physicians and patients engage in
conversations aimed at reducing
unnecessary tests and procedures in 2015
the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation award
a second grant to the ABIM foundation to
continue this important work so by way
of illustration let's talk about the
Duke bleeding time wwq was at Johns
Hopkins University and just two years
out of medical school when he
established that platelets come from
bone marrow megakaryocytes that they are
needed in blood clotting and that low
platelet counts were associated with
bruising and with bleeding dr. Duke
developed the bleeding time test
actually it was first reported in 1902
by French physicians and it may have
been around for a long time before that
but Duke actually developed the test and
wrote some guidelines he said we should
puncture the earlobe with a surgical
blade start a timer dab the wound with
filter paper every 30 seconds until the
bleeding stops then stopped the timer
and the normal range is between one and
nine minutes prolongation could go to as
far as 30 or 40 minutes and would signal
a low platelet count a functional
abnormality of platelets von Willebrand
factor deficiency called von Willebrand
disease or low or missing fibrinogen
call
a fibrinogen emia the earlobe wasn't
such a great idea
in fact I've done several of the Duke
bleeding times myself on ear lobes and
if it's cold you can't get any blood out
of an earlobe at all and so some folks
modified it and collected the sample
from a fingertip instead well an
improvement was developed in 1935 by dr.
AC IV who standardized the bleeding time
war by suggesting that you place a blood
pressure cuff on the upper portion of
the arm inflate it to 40 millimeters of
mercury and make an incision parallel to
the length of the arm on the forearm
inner surface this photo that's on this
slide is a little hard to decipher but
it is actually a photo taken in the 40s
of one of dr. Ivy's who were medical
student assistants who had many many
bleeding times done and they were
checking to see if the cut should be
parallel or perpendicular to the arm so
you're looking at an arm with dozens of
parallel and perpendicular cuts and as
you can see it left scars
by the way I've allowed students of mine
to practice on my arm and I have so many
scars on my arm now tends to alarm the
Red Cross people when I go to donate
blood the bleeding time is used as a
screen to predict surgical bleeding from
the time of a C IV and people with
prolonged bleeding times were taken off
the surgery schedule I have personal
experience with this when I was 14 years
old I had a tonsillectomy it was my
first time in a hospital laboratory and
there the laboratory technician did the
little cut on my arm dad and got the
timing and explained to me that it was a
way to predict whether I would bleed in
surgery tonsillectomy is actually has
some risk of bleeding there's about a 1
risk of post-operative hemorrhage in
tonsillectomy so it seemed like a really
good idea to perform the test well
doctor CH milky in 1969 improved further
on the test by developing a little metal
template that you could press onto the
arm and then make the incision with the
surgical blade and try to make it
standardized to one to two millimeters
deep by ten millimeters long the soon
was developed as the simply by a company
that was formed called international
techni dine and they had a little call
that an automated device where you could
click on a little trigger the blade
would come out it would make a precise
cut and exactly like the milky bleeding
time the sim plate was a little bit of a
risk because the blade would stay
exposed and so it would be a risk to the
operator and to anybody who collected
the trash so a rival company developed
the surgical which had a little blade
that actually swept and made the cut and
then would disappear inside and so it
was a little simpler international
techni dine bought this device actually
bought out the company that made it
called it the sir continue to call it
the surgeon cut and then they got bought
out by a company that in turn got bought
out by the company instrumentation
laboratory and that that's who owns it
today now I'd like to explain something
called the receiver operator curve or
the receiver operating characteristic
curve this
a statistical test that is done by
outcomes researchers what they do is
they will compare the false positive
rate if you can see it on the screen
that's down here and the true positive
rate here at every decision point
in a test that's a continuous variable
if the curve forms a nice dogleg as you
see there that's a good test the this
can be done just in in you can collect
the data in a regular excel file but you
need an integrator that measures the
area under the curve and if the area
under the curve is around 0.9 it's a
good test if you do the test in the area
under the curve is about 0.7 and the
curve is flatter
that's a mediocre test and if you look
at the outcomes of a test where the area
under the curve is 50% you're then
looking at a laboratory test that is
equivalent to flipping a coin not very
useful
and so this was applied to the bleeding
time test and it turns out that the
bleeding time test is completely
ineffective when applying outcomes data
of this sort the publication that is on
this slide Channing Rogers reviewed over
200 primary publications that looked at
the efficacy of the bleeding time test
in terms of its ability to predict
bleeding particularly in surgery or in
other circumstances as well and they
showed first of all the standardization
by IV and milky and so on did
I'd enhance the bleeding time whatsoever
didn't help with its Rock analysis the
bleeding time is not a specific
indicator of platelet function at all
it's affected by hematocrit by platelet
count that's affected by the thickness
of the skin by how intact the blood
vessels are and so on it does not
predict the risk of hemorrhage and
surgery or in any other condition the
prolongation doesn't occur ahead of
actual bleeding symptoms you'll be if
you lean times prolong chances are
you've already noticed bruises on your
arms and legs and it's not useful in
testing the efficacy of therapy now we
did use the bleeding time back in the
90s to see if aspirin was affected
aspirin will prolong the bleeding time
because it disables platelets however
that that testing got dropped in favor
of tests that are much more specific and
reproducible so just in summary the
bleeding time even though intuitively
seems like a great idea
it is useless and it leaves scars now
despite these findings it still is
available it's being sold still by
instrumentation laboratory and it is
being used around the world however it
is best to discourage the use of the
bleeding town as it really has no
predictive value the information that's
been collected on the bleeding time was
summarized in this choosing wisely
recommendation developed by the american
society for clinical pathology and it
simply says don't use the bleeding time
test to guide base pay tient care the
bleeding time test is an old assay that
has been replaced by alternative
coagulation tests the relationship
between the bleeding time test and the
risk of a patient's actually bleeding
has not been established further the
test leaves a scar on the forearm there
are other reliable tests of coagulation
available to evaluate the
risks of bleeding in appropriate patient
populations most laboratory directors I
will say have tried to ensure that none
of these surgical are around and that
people aren't doing the bleeding time
test anymore
a more sophisticated test is the per
thrombin timer the PT or the protein
that was developed by dr. Armand quick
in 1935 the pro time is prolonged by
deficiencies of many coagulation factors
plasma coagulation factors of the
extrinsic and the common pathways I have
a diagram in a moment to explain that
and so factors 10 10 7 5 and to cause
prolongation of the prothrombin time and
so this liver disease disseminated
intravascular coagulation and vitamin K
deficiency
dr. quick used it as an early test for
liver disease because the liver makes
all of these factors and then in 1953
when we started using the oral
anticoagulant coumadin which had been
been developed in the 1940s as rat
poison it turned out to be effective in
preventing ongoing thrombosis and we
then began testing for cumin in therapy
using the pro time which was further
refined to the International normalized
ratio in 1980 and furthermore we now
have the prothrombin time as a standard
admission screening protocol at all
medical centers likewise we have the
activated partial thromboplastin time it
was started in 1968 and it's gone
through several rit reiterations
iterations like the reek alton
then the Kaelin clotting time the
partial thromboplastin time and then the
activated partial
plastun time depending upon how the
reagent was formulated the activated
partial thromboplastin time had in it
phospholipid calcium and a negatively
charged activator now that's the only
kind of partial thromboplastin time test
we use nowadays so most of us have gone
back to just calling it the PTT we've
dropped the a from the name and it's
prolonged by deficiency deficiencies of
the coagulation factors twelve eleven
nine eight ten five and two and has also
been applied to monitoring
unfractionated heparin in inpatients
since 1970 but in addition to that the
PTT is now part of a standard admission
screening protocol for all hospitals
this slide diagrams the coagulation
mechanism and if you start over at this
point the extrinsic mechanism starts
with activation of factor seven by
tissue factor and it goes down this
pathway activating ten and five there's
ten there's five and activating thrombin
and eventually converting by Branigan to
fibrin which forms the clot the
prothrombin time reagent includes tissue
factor that emulates this material
calcium and phosphate idle serine which
is a phospholipid and it starts
coagulation at this point it triggers
factor seven activation and on down
through 10 and 5 and thrombin and fibrin
imogen on the other hand
the PTT reagent that consists of calcium
a particulate activator that's
negatively charged and phosphatidyl
serine triggers coagulation at the level
of factor 12 factor 12 then activates
1111 activates 9 8 is part of that
complex and then that goes on to
activate 10 and 5 which are part of the
common pathway and so the PTT and the PT
together measure coagulation
deficiencies in every part of the
coagulation mechanism what's happened
since then is that the PT and the PTT
are used as a screening combination
they're ordered on every surgical
ignition nearly every medical admission
and are repeated periodically in people
as they are in the hospital they're
ordered also in cases of outpatient
activity and anything that is
potentially bloody including the
tonsillectomy of bronchoscopy cardiac
catheterization we do so many of these
that in fact an 800 bed hospital such as
the one that I'm affiliated with at the
University of Alabama at Birmingham will
do somewhere between 300 and 500 PT and
PTT combinations a day and their purpose
is to screen for bleeding risk now I had
a personal incident in 2012 I had a bong
cos Coupee the head of the department of
pulmonology at UAB ordered a protime and
PTT on me I knew that they weren't
really predictive I'll show you in a
moment but I let her do it anyway they
were normal and I asked her why she did
the proton
and she said only to avoid lawsuits and
I asked did the pro time and PTT I asked
her does the pro time and PTT ever turn
up a positive and cause you to change
your mind on surgery and she said no
never once that's never happened
now just explain for a moment the
concept of a false positive and false
negative a true positive is an SI result
that correctly identifies those with a
disease or condition a false positive
that's an assay result that incorrectly
identifies a disease were none as
present of false alarm the true negative
and false negative have similar meanings
now you might ask well aren't laboratory
tests absolute either they're positive
or negative only in your dreams
Oh laboratory tests have a percentage of
true positives and false positives now
to explain a screening test we use the
term screen rather indiscriminately but
a screen actually has a specific meaning
and that is a test on an unselected or
random population that's like if you
were in the mall doing cholesterol
screening on anybody who comes by
if you devise a screening test you want
it to be as sensitive as possible so it
doesn't miss anybody but it will then
have a high false positive rate and a
low false negative rate if you use a
screen and it comes out positive you
then need a confirmatory test that's
designed the opposite way to have a high
false negative rate and a low false
positive rate and that can confirm the
initial screen you wouldn't want to use
the confirmatory test first because then
your false negatives rate would go up a
false positive
is it it creates a lot of extra work
because you have to do follow-up testing
if you have a high false positive rate
you tend to alarm a lot of patients with
these positive results and you often
have to delay a procedure or a surgical
event for a patient who has a positive
laboratory test although it turns out to
be false now high false negative rate is
more dangerous because you might miss an
existing disorder but it's okay to use a
more specific test as a confirmatory
test if you've already done the screen
this slide will be a little confusing
but it illustrates what happens if
you're using a a screening test on
various populations so we're going we're
looking at a population of 10,000 people
and we know from public health studies
that 10% of these people in a selected
sample will be positive and therefore
will have the disease 10% of 10,000
means a thousand people will have the
disease 9,000 without if you are using a
test that has a 2% false positive rate
then about 980 of the test will be true
positives out of that 1000 but you will
have 180 false positives now let's say
you have an unselected or random
population but the disorder is fairly
common at 1%
now you're going to pick up 98 true
positives but twice as many false
positives let's say you have an uncommon
disorder at 0.1% then out of 10,000
people you would have 10 people with the
disease
9990 without you will have 9.8 or
roughly 10 true positives but 200 false
positives and you can see how the
numbers come out for a rare condition
here you would have 200 false positives
for every one true positive so at that
rate your laboratory is just chasing its
tail following up all of these false
positives so the PT and the PT t their
efficacy of screens has been reviewed by
this group in 2017 and they've looked at
for medical or surgical patients without
liver dysfunction or history of bleeding
or oral anticoagulant use the routine
testing of the protein and PT t has no
benefit in the assessment of bleeding
risk and they asked what does predict
surgical bleeding risk they looked at
something called the bleeding assessment
tool or the be a T and the bleeding
assessment tool developed by the
International International Society for
thrombosis and hemostasis is a carefully
devised questionnaire that physicians
may use to ask a patient if they've had
any bleeding episodes how serious they
were bleeding episodes among their
kindred and so on well it turns out that
the group that reviewed this the B 80 by
is th it turns out that the B 80 wasn't
really much better at predicting
bleeding than was the proton the PTT or
the bleeding time the only thing that
really predicts bleeding in surgery is
the surgeons own track record in
previous beliefs
this information has led to another
choosing wisely recommendation again by
a SCP and they say avoid routine
preoperative testing for low-risk
surgeries without a clinical indication
it goes on to say most preoperative
tests typically a complete blood count
to thrombin time partial thromboplastin
time the basic metabolic panel and
urinalysis performed on elective
surgical patients are normal findings
influence management in under 3 percent
of patients tested and in almost all
cases no adverse outcomes are observed
when clinically stable patients undergo
elective surgery irrespective of whether
an abnormal test is identified
preoperative testing is appropriate and
symptomatic patients and those with risk
factors for which diagnostic testing can
provide clarification of patient
surgical risk so the question is are the
Protomen PTT useless no they're not if
there is an indication if the patient
has a bleeding disorder then those tests
are useful as a screen however almost
all they do is produce false positives
and create a lot of work and expense for
the laboratory and using the choosing
wisely recommendation can cut back on
laboratory expense patient anxiety
changes in the surgery schedule and all
for no particular reason one more
example I want to bring up is the
inherited thrombosis risk factors or
thrombophilia testing so in 1965 egg
Berg demonstrated that antithrombin
which is a control protein in
coagulation
when it is deficient is associated with
thrombosis and so laboratory medicine
specialists at that time thought AHA we
have the answer we can test for
antithrombin and we can predict it
you're going to have a thrombotic event
well it turns out that it's association
was relatively rare but then in 1984
1986 comp and Esmond described protein c
and protein s those were just named for
their location on poly acrylamide gel
electrophoresis so we started testing
those in 1986 it really didn't catch on
again because the prevalence was low but
in 1993 bjorn de baak in sweden
described activated protein c resistance
and in 1994 Roshi air Bertina
in the Netherlands described the actual
mutation associated with activated
protein C resistance and show that it
was quite prevalent in Caucasian
populations followed up in 1996 dr port
and the u.s. described the per thrombin
g 2210 mutation and then others to
looked at mutations in factor 8 in
homocysteine emia and in polymorphisms
of the methylene tetrahydrofolate
reductase enzyme well so most
laboratories developed a screening
profile that included activated protein
c resistance prothrombin antithrombin
deficiency almost cysteine and so on I
was associated with a clinical reference
laboratory in Denver that laboratory had
four employees in 1994 it was a fairly
specialized laboratory and was a fairly
small business
as soon as daubach described the APC our
and Bertina the factor v leiden the
prevalence of these what you see is 3.8
percent was such that it drove a huge
amount of business to reference
laboratories around the world in the
laboratory I'm referring to in Denver
that had four employees in 1994 had 40
employees by 1997 and had to move to
larger facility to accommodate the
volume of work however it turns out that
thrombophilia testing is limited
antithrombin is an acute phase reactants
so it's level rises in any case of acute
inflammation protein CNS their activity
actually drops in acute inflammation and
furthermore they are vitamin k dependent
and so if someone is on coumadin therapy
then they will the their results will go
down and all three have a high false
positive rate so in 2004 dr. Musa Markus
who I worked with at University of
Alabama at Birmingham and I examined
three years worth of thrombophilia test
profiles
that's our profile and we found that
over the three-year period we found that
over a three year period there were 20
percent of the protein C and protein s's
were deficient making you think that
these were all people who had a combined
protein C and protein s deficiency now
the prevalence or the possibility of
both being deficient
is 130 thousand so it's quite unlikely
we heard a talk by dr. Craig kitchens
from Jacksonville who
said that he knew of a lady who was
pregnant who was told she had protein C
and protein s deficiency the risk of
thrombosis was so high that her
physician told her to abort the
pregnancy and she did well the reality
is that the protein C and s levels are
low because they were ordered at the
wrong time while the patient was on
coumadin therapy the crewmen in therapy
causes both C and s levels to become
diminished and so with problems like
these a lot of work has gone into
looking at from thrombophilia testing
indications and the most important piece
of work that has been done was developed
by dr. Ravi sir OD at the Department of
Pathology in the University of Texas
Southwestern Medical Center in Dallas
and so what he did he is looked at 2
months of thrombophilia testing people
from in in 2009 and it's just a
retrospective study they just looked
through all of the electronic health
records and they looked at the
indications that should accompany
thrombophilia testing including the
current pregnancy loss of 3 or more
instances an unprovoked arterial
thrombosis or venous thrombosis or
pregnancy morbidity preeclampsia
intrauterine growth retardation and they
examine the total of 173 thrombophilia
test panels they also listed those test
panels that were done on people who had
non indications and this included
provoked venous thrombosis meaning have
having a clot form in your leg because
of immobilization or surgery or
malignancy a lot of people get clots in
their legs if they spend 812 hours in
the economy class part of an airplane
also provoked arterial thrombosis
associated with hypertension
dyslipidemia and so on people women with
one to two pregnancy losses or testing
with no prior thrombotic event so they
they listed both indications and non
indications and they found of their 173
patients that 29% of the patients had
testing performed without any documented
thrombotic event or pregnancy morbidity
80% who had a connective tissue or
autoimmune disorder another 69% had a
known thrombotic event or pregnancy loss
but 34% of those didn't have the
appropriate indication they also noted
that 59 of their patients were on
anticoagulant 146 patients had
incomplete workups and a hundred and
thirty-six of the patients had no
follow-up tests and altogether 85% of
their thrombosis risk orders were
inappropriate and so they developed an
intervention first of all they wrote
first of all they developed a laboratory
advisory committee and the group wrote
do not perform thrombophilia testing of
patients admitted with an acute venous
thromboembolism BOCES or patients
diagnosed with a thrombotic event during
their hospital stay
essentially what they're saying is don't
do these thrombophilia panels on anybody
who's an inpatient they went on to say
investigators outpatients if they met
the criteria young age unprovoked in
that they had to do the testing greater
than two weeks following discontinuation
of
coagulation and they shouldn't be done
if the patient is newly admitted with a
thrombotic event a beam Istanbul embolic
disorder pulmonary embolus or heart
attack because during acute inflammation
periods the tests are not at all
reliable they actually put hard stops
into their their laboratory electronic
ordering system which of course made a
lot of physicians angry but the
hemostasis service would communicate
with those clinicians to either cancel
the testing that was deemed
inappropriate or to go ahead and give
permission for testing if it seemed
appropriate
so as necessary for the physicians to
communicate with the hemostasis service
and it turned out that instead of doing
87 tests per month it was reduced to 18
tests per month and reduced even further
to 5 per month by intervention by the
hemostasis service so they reduced
theirs their orders on inpatients by 79%
79% sounds pretty good but in fact dr.
Cerrone was dissatisfied with that
number because still 21% of inpatients
were being tested for thrombophilia
inappropriately and so they continued to
attempt to educate because of his work
and the work of his group dr. Zarate was
awarded the choosing wisely champion
status because he discovered
approximately 85% of thrombophilia tests
at UT Southwestern Stu Teaching
Hospitals were ordered incorrectly or
incompletely thrombophilia tests are
frequently ordered for patients with
acute thrombotic events often while
antah on anticoagulation therapy however
these additional variables cause these
standard tests to return false positive
results
these abnormal results by false positive
they mean low or deficient results by
the way these are normal results are not
always checked for reproducibility or
accuracy causing some patients to be
inappropriately placed on long-term
anticoagulation therapy to promote
appropriate use of testing dr. Cyril
Dee's team developed local guidelines
and implemented them in the electronic
health record via a series of cascading
questions that providers must answer
before ordering after implementation of
the intervention and the associated
education campaign UT Southwestern has
now reduced testing for inpatients by
more than 90 percent and this has also
resulted in to choosing wisely
recommendations that are roughly
parallel one by the American Society for
hematology their logo right here in
which they say don't test for
thrombophilia in adult patients with
venous thromboembolism occurring in the
setting of major transient risk factors
such as surgery trauma or prolonged
immobility and you can read the rest of
that recommendation yourself and because
another even more specific
recommendation came from a SCP in which
they say do not test for protein s
protein C or antithrombin during an
active clotting event to diagnose a
hereditary deficiency these tests are
not analytically accurate during an
active clotting event
I'm currently dealing with a question on
fritzman factor about exactly how long
you should wait after an active clotting
event and the answer is you can't test
during the active clotting event or
immediately after and of course the
patient is going to be placed on
anticoagulants there
probably coumadin or nowadays it could
be one of the oral direct anticoagulants
like the bigot ran or rivaroxaban and
generally speaking it's a good idea to
wait two weeks after the treatment is
discontinued to then test for protein C
protein s or antithrombin or any of the
other thrombophilia factors with the
idea that by that time the anticoagulant
is cleared and you can get an accurate
result on an outpatient juicing wisely
has a champions program which the
participating associations recognize
clinicians who are leading efforts to
reduce the overuse and waste in medicine
the program was created to acknowledge
the work of those dedicated to providing
appropriate care and encourage others to
follow their lead
champions are selected by participating
societies and include clinicians or
teams of clinicians whose work in their
respective specialties represents
significant contributions to advancing
the goals of the campaign these can
include creation of an intervention to
implement choosing wisely in their
clinical practice designing local
initiatives to educate colleagues or
playing a leadership role in developing
society recommendations and here are
just a few examples three of several
champions from 2017 mr. Jack Jordan at
Henry Ford Hospital work to make
utilization of laboratory services more
evidence-based dr. megan cap who was at
vanderbilt worked with steering
committees these were called diagnostic
management teams educating the house
staff and faculty about the harm of
daily labs and in fact people in ICU
an average of 60 to 70 milliliters of
blood drawn every day often rendering
them anemic dr. pelage published
research that contributed to the
infectious disease Society of America
saying that there was overuse of tests
for Clostridium difficile in certain
situations or c-diff here's four of the
2016 champions the cedars-sinai health
system actually cut six million dollars
in laboratory testing dr. Alton burger
decreased blood product usage by forty
six percent over three years I'll have a
additional comment on that a moment dr.
Juarez addressed variability and blood
utilization at Baylor and she and her
colleagues developed an institutional
clinical practice recommendation
modifying transfusion workflow in the
EHR and launching a an educational
campaign and also dr. Munoz and his
colleagues at banner Anderson Cancer
Center implemented an intervention
design to test whether an automatic
alert in an EHR could remind clinicians
to carefully weigh the anticipated
benefits against the risks of post
treatment imaging scans
for patients with lymphoma there's also
the choosing wisely grant program that I
mentioned at the very beginning these
are grants from the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation these grants have supported
21 projects led by state medical
societies and in 2015 an additional
seven grants to organizations that
promote the goals of the choosing wisely
program and those grants are ongoing and
choosing wisely regularly announced new
grants as well
well there's well more than 100
recommendations and so I just threw in a
couple of additional examples one
everybody probably knows about the old
erythrocyte of sedimentation rate and
this came from the SCP they say don't
order an ESR to look for inflammation in
patients went with undiagnosed
conditions order a c-reactive protein to
detect acute phase inflammation that's a
much better essay the ESR should be
eliminated altogether in addition to
laboratory testing I didn't talk much
about their therapy but there's many
recommendations associated with the
overuse of therapy the one that turns up
over and over and is best expressed by
the American Association of blood banks
is blood usage recommendation and they
say don't transfuse more units of blood
than absolutely necessary back in the
80s and 90s the rule was if you're going
to transfuse you better give them to not
just one because one isn't likely enough
that has been completely reversed and
now the recommendation is to restrict
blood to when the hemoglobin level is
low much slide shows the recommendation
from choosing wisely at 7 to 8 grams of
hemoglobin but many positions even use 6
grams of hemoglobin and to use only a
single unit of red blood cells for that
treatment that's a typical
recommendation now I won't read the next
three slides to you I'll give you the
opportunity to look at these themselves
but this represents a recommendation by
a FCP that was sent to Consumer Reports
and was made of and is made available to
the lay public and it's a recommendation
about vitamin
detesting and it illustrates that we do
way too much vitamin D testing wasting a
lot of money and it is pitched not to
the physician but to the lay individual
it's in intelligent terms but in lay
terms that most people can read and they
say I'll just read the bottom of this
slide says many people have low levels
of vitamin D but few have seriously low
levels most of us don't need a vitamin D
test we just need to make simple changes
so we get enough vitamin D you need to
get a little more Sun eat foods rich in
vitamin D or take a supplement and the
recommendation goes on it says extra
tests lead to extra treatment and costs
getting tests that you don't need often
leads to treatments you don't need or
treatments that can even be harmful for
example if you take too much vitamin D
it can damage your kidneys and other
organs this is continued on this third
slide and I won't really read that
that's available for you to take a look
at what I want to get to is this the
choosing wisely people are always
looking for more societies to
participate if your society would like
to participate they need to submit 5
recommendations for consideration
they must begin with the terms don't or
avoid they have to be evidence-based
with current references they must
address frequent diagnostic or
therapeutic choices they're developed
within the contributing society using
their own processes and they may send
recommendations that overlap with other
existing recommendations or conversely
they should try to avoid complete
redundancy choosing wisely
recommendations are developed with
transparency the method is summarized
with the recommendation they're
accompanied by a description of the
contributing Society
and the foundation sent seats
recommendation to two independent
reviewers for comment and approval the
foundation then sends recommendations to
all the partners to ensure that there's
no conflict with existing
recommendations and when the
recommendations are finally published
the copyright actually belongs to the
contributing society so our last
question is is choosing wisely working
and just in October on October 25 2017
just a week ago there was a working
study that looked at the outcomes of the
choosing wisely activity only one in
four US doctors knows about choosing
wisely
it was 21% in 2014 now it's 25% there
was a slight non significant increase
since 2014 in the percentage who
reported difficulty having conversations
about avoiding low value services from
42 percent to 46 percent in 2017 and I'd
like to read to you the statement that
was issued by the meeting on the 25th
they said the choosing wisely campaign
represents a practical expression of the
core mission of the ABIM foundation to
improve healthcare by strengthening
medical professionalism
according to dr. Richard Barron
president and chief executive officer of
the ABIM and the foundation he said this
in his introductory remarks he continued
how do you get from the aspiration to do
the right thing to actually changing
behavior to frontline conversations and
frontline actions
that's what choosing wisely
is all about when the researchers asked
physicians why they continue to practice
services deemed to be low value they
listed malpractice concerns most often
followed by dealing with uncertainty and
patient demand implying that they're
actually answering patient demand to
have these unnecessary procedures and
treatments done however one of the
researchers pointed out that such
concerns don't align with the literature
on what is actually driving the
practices and their impact for example
the lead author of this effort Kari Cola
PhD noted in their paper that there is
little evidence that patients are
demanding these low value services or
that not offering them increases the
risk for malpractice suits so the
question is what to do next and the
answer to me is education education
education and in addition to that the
use of hard stops in your electronic
health record that brings the physicians
to the experts for advice and help that
concludes my talk I want to thank you
for listening today and I'll be happy to
entertain questions thank you very much
and thank you so much George for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window type
the questions into the box that appear
on the screen and click the send button
will enter as many questions as we have
time for so let's take a look at our
audience questions that are already
coming in George our first question from
our audience is what can MLS educators
do to promote the choosing wisely
program I'll tell you a project that I'm
involved in right now and that is I'm
involved with the American Society for
Clinical Laboratory Sciences and the AF
CLS most of our members over half of our
members are medical laboratory science
educators in many universities and even
hospitals around the country and we've
organized a task force within AS CLS of
eight members who are looking at
involvement with choosing wisely and
with developing recommendations and the
key effort that we're involved in is
developing educational modules that can
be fit into entry level education for
medical laboratory scientists Advanced
Education for medical laboratory
scientists and also for residents
hematology fellows medical students
nurse practitioners nurses and physician
assistants and I think educating at the
level of entry into the profession will
have a profound difference
thank you so much George and thank you
audience members we do have one more
question from our audience
what about instructing patience can you
give us a little information about that
George Z as far as instructing patience
go we I personally number one I think
Consumer Reports is a great way to
access the public the lay public I think
also those of us who are involved in
choosing wisely have an obligation to
make presentations to people at let's
say civic organizations churches or
other associations within our own
communities important that we use later
monologist elegent later my knowledge ii
that people can understand we don't want
to insult people with simplistic terms
but we want to make sure that people
understand how so many of these
activities that we do in medicine are
unnecessary and potentially harmful so
that's to me the key is finding ways to
get to the lay public with this kind of
information thank you so much George and
would you like to offer any closing
remarks before we end our presentation
today I just have a couple of quick
things to say Suzy it is difficult there
have been many studies that show that
educational efforts designed to change
practices in medicine might be heated
for a while let's say you have a Grand
Rounds you have
discussion of some of the choosing
wisely issues everyone agrees they go
back to their practice and there's no
change in their performance I know of
one researcher who has developed a
little 30-minute case based in yes that
help that physicians can get CME or
others can get accreditation from
nursing societies or medical lab science
societies and they can participate in
these brief little vignettes and get
credit and this researcher has designed
the back end of that program such that
it measures behaviors before
participation and after that seems to be
one of the more effective ways to change
behavior the other one is I've already
mentioned I think is at entry level
education where you can help show people
what testing is important what therapy
is important and what is overused and
can be possibly harmful
thank you George
Fritz ma and thank you audience members
for this wonderful presentation I'd also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
2018 you're receiving email from lab
roots letting you know when the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye